we are in London right now we are the
Bianca Jagger human rights foundation
and Miss Jagger is sitting next to me
she's the president of this foundation
thank you so much for this interview
miss Jagger what is happening in
Nicaragua right now you were there too
some weeks ago and the situation is
really devastating what happened to
Nicaragua used to be it used to be one
of the safest countries in Central
America thank you for having me and a
new program well it's true that
Nicaragua was one of the safest
countries in Central America and perhaps
one of the safest countries in Latin
America but what people didn't really
know was what was happening in Nicaragua
since the election and maybe for quite a
few years Daniel Ortega didn't become a
dictator overnight Daniel Ortega has
become a murderous dictator in the last
few weeks this is a brutal murderous
government who is killing the people and
who's killing must be understood that
they are killing an unarmed population
this is in non-violence resistance and
when I was in Nicaragua I was able to
march with people and during this march
on Mother's Day where they were women
all the people families hundreds of
thousands of people from Nicaragua on
that day he killed 18 people do you
think the world is paying enough
attention to what is happening right now
in Nicaragua no some of the Latin
American countries have begun to
understand what's happening in Nicaragua
but overall for example I think the
German media have given much more
attention to Nicaragua than say the
British media it seems like the British
media doesn't really care much about
what's happening in Nicaragua as you
know already this weekend the death
squads together with the police attack
the students at the same University I
visited while I was in the crowd were
with this Union which is the autonomous
Nicaraguan University and where is all
the headlines about all the students
been attacked and being killed
while the well the people who are at
kingdom were hired just like I saw
before weapons of war losses and acha
47s and other Russian weapons and the
students all they had were slings and
stones and that's all they had to defend
themselves and making notes and
improvised firework that they used to to
sort of make noise against them all I
can say is that I make an appeal to the
to the European Union to the German
government to the Austrian government to
the European countries you know to speak
up I mean there is the United States is
using the magnet Mineski act to to
impose it or to punish some of the
people we hope that they will put that
will apply that to Daniel Ortega what I
feel at the moment is that the the the
there is a slaughter against the people
every day a slaughter against innocent
people who are unarmed we cannot allow
that to happen why we allow that to
happen why is the international
community why is the British press not
interested in Nicaragua are all children
not worth for them to report it clear
words from mr. Tucker thank you so much
for this interview that was miss Bianca
Jagger here from London for tw